the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
alright guys so today I'm not gonna be
doing most of the talking you actually
are because like I've said we've been
teaching you all sorts of crazy physics
and radiation biology we've taught you
how to smell [ __ ] taught you a
little bit about how to read papers and
what to look for and we're gonna spend
the second half of today's class
actually doing that well we're gonna
have a mini debate on whether or not or
basis is real and you guys are gonna
spend some time finding evidence for or
against it instead of just me telling
you this is what hormesis is or isn't so
just to finish up the multicellular
effects from last time we started
talking about what's called the
bystander effect which says if a cell is
irradiated and it dies or something
happens to it the other cells nearby
notice may speed up their metabolism or
their oxidative metabolism which can
generate some of the same chemical
byproducts as radiolysis does causing
additional cell damage in mutation and
there was an interesting yeah I think
I'd lie we left off here at this study
or they actually talked about most of
the types of mutations found in the
bystander cells were of different types
but there were mutations found in this
case as a result of what's called
oxidative base damage this is oxidative
cell metabolism ramping up and producing
more of those metabolic byproducts that
can damage DNA as well but we didn't get
into is the statistics what do the
statistics look like for large sample
sizes of people who have been exposed to
small amounts of radiation I'm going to
show you a couple of them one of them is
the folks within 3 kilometers of the
Hiroshima so I want you to notice a
couple of things the LA here's the dose
in grey maxing out at about two gray and
in this case this er R is what's called
excess relative risk it's a little
different than odds ratio where here an
excess relative risk of zero means it's
like nothing happened so anything above
zero means extra excess relative risk so
what are some of the features you notice
about this data
what's rather striking about it in your
opinion yeah turn
this one oh yeah these are the errors
yep
what does it say here is it more than
one standard ever yep yeah I mean look
at the confidence in this data at high
doses and then while you may say okay
the amount of relative risk per amount
of radiation increases with decreasing
dose which is the opposite of what you
might think our confidence in that
number goes out the window now what do
you think of the total number of people
that led to each of these data points
how many folks you think we're exposed
to gray vs. milla gray of radiation
that's right the sample size I thought
it was cold and loud in here the sample
size for the folks in gray is much
smaller and yet the Arab bars are much
smaller too that's not usually the way
it goes is it usually you think larger
sample size smaller Arab bars unless the
effects themselves and confounding
variables are hard to tease out from
each other if you then look at another
set of people all of the survivors oh
yeah Charlie this would have to be from
some estimate these are we from models
it's not like folks had dosimeter x'
everywhere in Japan in the 1940s but
this V these would be estimates
depending on where you lived let's say
in an urban suburb in a rural area
let's see things like milk intake right
after the bomb or anything that would
have had given you an A usually high
amount of radiation distance where the
winds were going this is the best you
could do with that data and now look at
all of the bomb survivors including the
ones outside three-kilometer region but
still got some dose what's changed
it seems like they're less likely to get
more risk yet yeah the the conclusion is
almost flipped for the low dose cases if
you put them side by side depending on
the folks living within three kilometers
of the epicenter of Hiroshima versus
anyone exposed all the bomb survivors
you get an almost opposite conclusion
for low doses despite the numbers being
almost you know where they're within
each other's confidence intervals for
high doses so what this tells us is that
the effects of high dose are relatively
easy to understand and quite obvious we
even with low sample sizes what is
different between these two data sets
well it's the only difference that's
actually listed here distance from the
epicenter right so before I tell you
what's different I want you two guys to
try to think about what could be
different about the folks living within
three kilometers of the epicenter of
Hiroshima versus anyone else in the city
or the countryside yeah
could be yeah it might be harder to
figure out exactly how much dose folks
had without necessarily measuring it
right but what other major factors are
confounding variables are confusing the
data here yeah
so in this case these are for bomb
survivors so yes that's true if you're
closer you get the gamma blast you get
the pressure wave
it should just account all survivors
yeah sure absolutely
and then the other big one is you
actually someone's kind of mentioned it
but in passing urban or rural the
environment that you live in depends on
how quickly let's say the ecosystem
replenishes or not if you live in a city
or what sort of other toxins are
concentrated sources of radiation you
may be exposed to by living in a city
that's endured a nuclear attack or
something else could also depend on the
amount of health care that you're able
to receive if you show some symptoms of
something if you lived way out in the
countryside and there weren't a lot of
roads then maybe you can't get to the
best Hospital or you go to a clinic that
we don't know as much the point is
there's a lot of confounding variables
there's a lot more people but anything
from like lifestyle to diet two routes
of exposure think about the differences
in how folks in the city and out in the
countryside may have been exposed to the
same dose because again dose is given in
grey not in sieverts that's the best we
can estimate but would it matter if you
were too exposed to let's say alpha
particle containing fallout that you
would then ingest versus exposed to a
lot of gamma rays or delayed betas it
absolutely would so the type of
radiation and the route of exposure and
the organs that were affected are not
accounted for in the study because again
the data is in grey it's just an
estimated joules per kilogram of
radiation exposure not taking into
account the quality factors for tissue
the quality factors for type of
radiation the routes of exposure the
dose rate which we've already talked
about how much you got as a function of
time actually does matter so all these
things are quite important and for all
these sorts of studies you have to
consider the statistics so let's now
look at a
say okay a cellphone like study where
one might draw a conclusion if the error
bars weren't drawn so based on this can
you say that very low doses of radiation
in this area actually give you some
increased risk of what do they say
female breast cancer no you can't be
bold enough to draw a conclusion from
the very low dose region from let's say
the the ones to tens of milligram at
whole region right there that people are
afraid of getting we don't actually know
if it hurts or it does nothing or if it
helps that's a kind of weird thing to
think about so the question is what do
we do next these are the actual
recommendations from the our CRP and
I've highlighted the parts that are
important in my opinion for everyone to
read and the most important one probably
will have to come to terms with some
uncertainty in the amount of damage that
little amounts of dose do so this is the
ICRP saying to the general public you
guys should chill out there's not much
we can do about tiny amounts of exposure
they happen all the time
you can either worry about it and get
your heart rate up and elevate your own
blood pressure and have a higher chance
of dying on your own or you can just
chill out because there is not enough
evidence to say whether a tiny little
amount of radiation and we're talking in
the mill agreeable Oh helps or hurts or
does nothing which leads me into the
last set of slides for this entire
course they're not that long because I
want you guys to actually do a lot of
the work here is radiation hormesis real
or not there are plenty of studies
pointing one way or the other and I want
to show you a few of them with some
other examples the whole idea here is
that a little bit of a bad thing can be
a good thing
much like vitamins or let's say vitamin
A and seal livers tiny little bit of it
you need it's a vital micronutrient
whole lot of it can do a whole lot of
damage you don't usually think of that
being the case for radiation but some
studies may have you believe otherwise
with surprisingly high sample sizes so
the idea here is that if you've got any
not just element and diet but anything
that happens to you there's going to be
some optimum level where you could die
or have some ill effects if exposed to
too much or too little we all know that
this happens with high amounts of
radiation the question is is that
actually happen so let's look at some of
the data in this case I mentioned
selenium and actually have a fair bit of
this data that shows some let's say
contradictory results in this case where
a whole lots of different people were
exposed to a certain amount of selenium
accidentally I don't think these were
any intentional studies but some folks
received massive doses of selenium and
try folks tried to figure out well what
you want to see how much they got
remember that you want about 5
micrograms per day on average that's a
pretty crazy amount of selenium that
ended up killing this person in 4 hours
but let's look at a sort of medium dose
something way higher than you'd normally
get two different studies published in
peer-reviewed places this one says
taking mega doses of selenium so
enormous doses may have cute toxic
effects and showed no decreased incident
of prostate cancer and increased
prostate cancer race rates 35 thousand
people the same supplements greatly
reduced secondary prostate cancer
evolution in another study kind of hard
to wrap your head around that right both
these studies were done with I'd say
enough people and came to absolutely
opposite conclusions showing that
there's definitely other confounding
variables at work here so there's kind
of two solutions to this problem
increase your sample size and try to get
a most representative set of the
population or control for other
confounding variables and then the
question is how do you model how much is
a good thing to go over what these
models mean the one that's described
right now and the public is called a
linear no-threshold model this means
that if this axis right here is bad and
this is axis right here is amount that
any amount of radiate
is bad for you what I think might be a
little bit more accurate is called the
linear threshold model if you remember
from two classes ago the ICRP recommends
that I think point o1 microsieverts is
considered nothing officially that would
mean there is a threshold below which we
absolutely don't care and if there are
any ill effects they're statistically
inseparable from anything else that
would happen and that would suggest here
this linear threshold model where this
control line right here would be the
incidence of whatever bad happens in the
control population not exposed to the
radiation the selenium or whatever
there's also a couple of other ones like
the hormesis model which says that if
you get no radiation you get the same
amount of ill effects as a control group
if you get a little radiation you
actually get less ill effects in this
case this would be like saying getting a
little bit of radiation to the lungs
could decrease your incidence of lung
cancer does anyone believe that idea
getting a little bit of dose to your
lungs could decrease lung cancer okay
and then you you reach some point of
crossover point where yeah a lot of this
thing becomes bad and the question is is
radiation hormetic does this region
where things get better actually lead
all the way to x equals zero as a
function of dose and I want to skip
ahead a little bit to some of the
studies no I don't want to skip ahead
there are some non hormetic models that
are been proposed in the literature it's
easy to wrap your head around a linear
model right it's just a line more is
worse but the question is how much so
folks have propor proposed things like
linear quadratic where a little bit of
dose is bad and then a lot more dose is
more bad as a function of dose that's
actually kind of what we saw in the
hiroshima data and i'll show you again
in a sec so the history of this LNT or
linear no-threshold model states the
following four things radiation exposure
is harmful well does anyone disagree
with that statement I think we all know
that even larger at least large amounts
of radiation exposures
bad it's harmful at all exposure levels
that's the one you have to wonder each
increment of exposure adds to the
overall risk saying that it's an always
increasing function and the rate of
accumulation exposure has no bearing on
risk the first one's easy we know this
is true because you expose people to a
lot of radiation bad things tend to
happen deterministically the second one
we already know is false if you look at
large sample sets of data like the data
we showed before there's definitely a
non-linear sort of relationship going
where each incremental amount of
exposure has the same amount of
incremental risk we know from a lot of
study that's not typically true then the
question is what about these two so now
it's gonna we're gonna find show you
some fairly interesting studies in this
case leukemia as a function of radiation
dose what do you guys think about this
data set before I see it any ideas into
your heads so here is dose in sieverts
not gray and here is odds ratio relative
risk of contracting leukemia if you were
to look at the data points alone what
would you say
yeah you might think that but look at
all the different types of models you
can draw through the error bars is you
could draw anything going let's say down
and then up you could draw a linear
no-threshold model as long as it got
through this line right here or a linear
quadratic model so a study like this
doesn't quite give you any sort of
measurable conclusion a study like this
might especially considering the number
of people involved in this case this is
the activity of radon and air as related
to the incidence of lung cancer per
10,000 people notice the sample size
here 200,000 people from 1600 counties
that comprise ninety percent of the
population
chances are you've then passed the
urban-rural divide you've then passed
any region of the country so by
including such a gigantic sample size
you do mostly eliminate the confounding
variables so location you know house
construction urban versus rural age
anything else are pretty much smeared
out in the enormous sample size and what
do you see here you see a fairly
statistically significant hormesis
effect where you know the route of
exposure is very well known everything
else seems to be controlled for by I
mean we've included something like
almost point 1 percent of the u.s.
population that's not bad other ones for
people that get more specific targeted
dose in this case women who received
multiple x-rays to monitor lung collapse
during tuberculosis treatment a group of
people that can be tightly controlled
and followed very well these are numbers
with one standard deviation and that
right there so you can see is set to
gray so this dose right here is one gray
worth of dose that's a pretty toasty
amount of radiation but below that again
statistically significant looking data
don't know how many people were in this
study cuz I didn't extract that
information but it's something you might
be doing in the next half an hour
oh it does this is deaths per 10,000
women but how many people were in the
study question is what is your sample
size so like in the last study there was
200,000 people in the samples that gives
you some pretty good confidence that
you've eliminated confounding results
though I don't know how many folks get
tuberculosis these days in the US or
whether this was even a US study chances
are the sample size is smaller so then
even if the data support your idea of
hormesis you have to call into question
is this a large enough and a
representative enough sample size to
draw any real conclusion slimthick let's
keep going more data needed evidence for
a threshold model this is probably the
most boring looking graph that actually
gives you some idea of should there be a
threshold for how much radiation is a
bad thing in this case it's very careful
date it's very carefully controlled set
data set lung cancer death from radon in
miners and folks that are going down
underground probably have a higher
incidence of lung cancer overall from
all the horrible stuff they're exposed
to whether it's coal or well you know if
you're mining gypsum oh there's lots of
nasty stuff down there but there's an
additional amount of deaths responsible
from radon here's your relative list
risk level of 1 and up to 10 picoCuries
per liter which was around the maximum
of the last study it's as boring as it
gets which helps refute the idea of a
linear no-threshold model because if
there was a linear no-threshold model
this DC this dose versus risk would be
reliably and significantly going up so
there's data out there to support this
and even even better ones lung cancer
deaths from radon in homes the stuff
study was careful to look at if you look
at the legend here these are different
cities ranging from Xianyang and China
to Winnipeg in Canada to New Jersey
which is apparently a city two places in
Finland Sweden and Stockholm which are
somehow different places yeah so when
you see a study like this where they
actually control and check to make sure
they're not getting any single locality
as an
representative measurement and the data
just looked like a crowd ecloudmanager
basement but pretty big studies and
quite a lot of them show that a little
bit isn't going to add any risk to you
so if you're worried about risk there
statistically is none based on quite a
few of these studies and in order to
enable you to find these studies on your
own I wanted to go through five minutes
of where to look and the answer is not
Google because Google is not very good
at finding every study it also picks up
a whole lot of garbage that's not
peer-reviewed because it just scrabbles
the Internet you know that's that's what
it does really well instead I want us to
take the next half hour split into teams
for and against hormesis
and try and find studies that confirm a
refute the idea that radiation hormesis
is an actual effect so how many of you
have some sort of computer II device
with you here good enough so that there
is equal amount in each group I'd like
to switch now to my own browser and I
want to show you guys the web of science
web
yeah MIT made us I use pine on my phone
it's much better science so if you're
just google search web of science and
you're at MIT it will recognize your
certificates and send you in to the
actual best scientific paper indexing
thing out there
oh my god it's better than Google
Scholar yeah if you think you found
everything by looking at Google Scholar
you're only fooling yourself you're not
fooling anybody else it's getting better
but it doesn't find anything and Google
Scholar is really good at finding things
that aren't peer-reviewed self-published
stuff things on archive things that you
can't trust because they haven't passed
the muster of the scientific community
so instead let's say you just do a
simple search for radiation hormesis you
can all do this don't worry I'm not
showing you how to search I'm showing
you some of the other features of web of
science you end up with 534 papers you
can let's say sort by number of times
cited which may or may not be a factor
in how trustworthy the data is and might
just correlate with the age of the paper
it might also be controversial so if
people cite it as an example of what to
do wrong it might be highly cited you
know people have made tenure cases and
like careers on papers that ended up
being wrong and all you see is ten
thousand citations saying this person's
an idiot
if the committee valued you know judging
you for promotion doesn't read that far
into it they're like oh my god ten
thousand citations right you boom tenure
that's all you have to do I think I have
it a little tougher the important part
is well with a title like that no man
the more the real fun part though is you
can see who has cited this paper so if
you want to then go see why has this
paper been cited 260 times you can
instantly see all the titles and years a
number of additional citations of the
papers that have cited it so this is how
you get started with a real research
research yeah that's what I meant to say
is starting from a paper in a tool like
web of science you can go forward and
backward in citation time backward in
time to see what evidence this paper
used to make their claims forward in
time to see what other people thought
about it so who wants to be for hormesis
all right everyone all you guys on one
side of the room all you guys are other
guys on the other side of the room and
I'd like you guys to try to find the
most convincing studies that you can to
prove the other side wrong I suggest
using web of science not Google Scholar
it's pretty easy to figure out how to
learn how to use and let's see what
conclusion we come to yep hormesis by
the walk yeah
aunty hormesis by the window there we go
and I'm gonna hide this because I don't
want to give anyone an unfair advantage
this is a graph showing the immune
response in the cells of mice showing
that after they were giving doses from
zero to two gray or zero to seven on the
right the response of the immune system
so at the lower doses below like 0.5
gray which is in the range that we're
looking at well the immune system in the
mice had a stronger response at low
doses of radiation and then very quickly
tapered off supporting the claim the low
doses are good for mice I have another
graph - yes so at higher doses the
response of the immune system was
suppressed which follows with what all
the other studies show about giving
doses in excess of like one gray - cells
so auntie herpes is crew I have another
graphic yeah oh no I have another graph
I have two of the same one now I have
another one somewhere I'll find it all
right so this one is incidences of lung
cancer based on mean radon level and
corrected for smoking so you can't say
that it was just from people smoking so
for radon levels up to 7 Pico Curie's
per liter the incidents of fatal lung
cancer actually decreased as you had
more radon
anything else you guys want to show
before the ending releases folks okay so
what I got I will try yes
so so a mouse is twice almost twice as
effective at fighting ominous
I have not
I'm not personally offended by this
you're good
if radiation witnesses had such a strong
effectiveness my sleep
but it really
I don't know that it was improvement I
think it was just in the amount of
response they saw I don't know if that
means it's well that doesn't always mean
it was effective at doing something
like how can something like the dose
range that small
well from 0 to half a gray is pretty
significant
it's like very
now I'm here for the pro Bernice's team
what mixture
what makes your legs a little shaky
trying to stand hold this up didn't read
the static you're only looking at one
type of cell which may or may respond
differently to different types of
radiation there are no error bars no not
even a whole mouth either to trigger an
immune response
that's like there are these other cells
nearby but they're like ah you're not
myself
that's another but yeah is it did it say
in the study how many again did not read
read the conclusions they do know alone
just take it at face value make it look
like Burmese this is a definite thing
yeah
yeah two nine mice cell samples all
right the the lung one this one has air
bars yeah one has error bars two
corrupted for smoking so let's see what
the caption says compared with us and
for multiple counties because it talks
about counties plural so
so multiple County has helped control
for single localities
past what
what's this average residential level of
1.7 so I think that means maybe some
people have less maybe I have some
people have more I don't know what the
minimum radon level is that's dr. B zero
it's not I don't know what kind of scale
that's on
yeah so this this is fairly convincing
if the point here was to show there's
the theory of linear no-threshold and
here's what's of actual data with narrow
bar shows it does a pretty good job at
saying theories not right in this case
can you say that in all cases it's hard
to tell in the first study you found
that was on the cellular level on maybe
the multicellular multicellular level
certainly now the organism level like we
said how many my excuse is just parts of
mice just it'll be the same Mouse yeah
this one is definitely at the organism
level is for for gross amounts of
exposure or how many of them resulted in
increased incidents of lung cancer the
answer is pretty much none they all
showed a statistically significant
decrease which is pretty interesting so
thanks a lot okay you just pull it out
okay are you sure yeah no pulling now
it's fine if you jam it in you can bend
the pins and that's happened here before
if you want to take a minute to send
each other the links go ahead
now I like this though is you can you
can find a graph that supports something
and you can cite it in a paper and you
can get that paper published but looking
more carefully at the data does
sometimes call things into questions
like I think you guys found a good
example of that Mouse cell study that
looks like it supports hormesis but you
can't say so for sure
make sure no one's waiting for the room
no one's kicking us out
interesting can you send me the link
yeah I mean we can't continue this
there's weird enough since we're not
going to the reactor since that valve
was broken keep it up yeah actually I
like this this would be a good quite a
good use of recitation I'll keep my
email open in case folks want to send
things to present so one of the one of
the main problems that we had with the
hormesis effect was that all the studies
that we've seen seem to cover a large
scope of liked issues different effects
and all sorts of things like yeah
there's a lot of studies there's a lot
of trends but like the things in
particular that they're studying are all
over the place and a lot of the a lot of
the research done like these studies
here are not actually meant to study
hormesis it's kind of like recycled data
that's used from some other study and
they're kind of like pulling from
multiple sources which increases the
uncertainty then additionally we have
conflicting epidemiological evidence of
low dosages so we're in one instance you
may see a reduction in breast cancer
mortality you'll see excess thyroid
cancer in children other other which is
in 1995 yeah and so I think we're not I
don't think we're trying to disqualify
Renesas as like completely wrong I think
one of the biggest issues that we're
taking with it is that it's a small
effect if anything it's something that
we really don't know about it's hard to
quantify and it's at the end of the day
really just not worth it not worth
looking into because of all of the
variable variables that go into it and
the effects that like we just don't know
about and we don't understand it so yeah
[Music]
can you tell me how that like you know
so the course what you're saying use my
life depart oh right now right up here
okay
we haven't seen in humans
medicine also is not accepted until it
works on humans not on animals so we
could cure cancer in rats all day but
look if it doesn't work in like a human
body and it just
we still don't use it like it needs to
clear the hurdle of human usefulness
before we actually use it
the data they also basically
that's interesting now how would one
interpret because you show the Cohen
data
so how would one interpret that to mean
no well I'm not trying to now determine
can this are the claims of this paper it
you can stand
and this brings up actually another
point they do agree that there's been
hundreds of cell and animal studies they
cite three human studies so since we
have the time you guys may want to look
for more than three human studies done
at the time of this writing it's not
fair to take ones that were done
afterwards let's find out
let's hit the bar
mm yeah
yeah so if you want to refute that point
you may want to find more human studies
pre-2000 would be fair to do otherwise
but actually I liked what you said so
what you're proposing is that most
people should adopt the model it looks
something like this this is the axis of
how much bad or that's zero and this is
dosent gray and whether your model does
this or this or this it sounds to me
like you are defining a like you're
defining a chill zone the same EBG yes
the effect may be so small that who
cares but the bigger discussion is how
much is bad yeah like maybe it does look
like this but the dip is small really
not that different from the linear
threshold model so in addition to being
a basic science question could the issue
of hormesis almost be a sidetrack in
getting proper radiation policy
that's a point I hadn't heard made
before but I quite like it because it's
not like you're going to recommend
everyone smokes three cigarettes a day
or you know everyone gets blasted by a
little bit of radiation once a year as
part of a treatment I don't think anyone
would buy that even if it did help I
don't think anybody could emotionally
but by focusing on video there's a nice
expression is the most important thing
is make the most important thing the
most important thing is don't lose sight
of the overall goal which is if you're
making policy on how much radiation
exposure you're allowed do you focus on
saying a little bit is actually good or
do you focus on saying here's the amount
that's bad and anything below that we
shouldn't be regulating or over
regulating because there's no evidence
to say whether it's good or bad
outside the Joseph quite liked that
point
it means that the supporters of
radiation should chill down as well all
right so any other studies we had a
couple abstracts
okay
do you want to come up
so what they're saying is the the choice
of model really doesn't matter as long
as it fits through the data that we've
got and it seems to be again what
happens in the low dose regime is less
important right
I knew they were satisfied
so they're saying the best estimate of
this that's funny if a rich model with a
threshold is assumed the best estimate
is below zero secrets but then how is
their confidence interval from Oh
less than zero two point one three they
don't quantify how much lower it goes
because if negative dose doesn't make
sense
so yeah it's a strong conclusion but
looks looks fairly well supported to say
that we can't say with those confidence
intervals that they give if there is
there isn't the threshold interesting
what do you guys think of this
- what would you delve into the study to
try to agree with or refute this claim
they use it with your quadratic model
looks like
considering
that's catchy but it just seems like
it'd be very easy to consider
sure you know what no study has gotten
into yet is what's the mechanism of
let's say ill effect acceleration this
is something that at least at the grad
school level we try hammer into everyone
constantly is not just what's the data
but what's the mechanism what's the
reason for an acceleration of ill
effects so if you guys have to think
with increasing gradiation exposure
let's say we went with this linear
quadratic model idea what could be some
reasons or mechanisms for an increased
amount of risk per unit dose as the dose
gets higher yeah
sure we're free yeah I like that idea
there was that you've got some capacity
to deal with damage from radiation and
then once you exceed that capacity you
don't also was like with higher dose we
don't also ramp up your capacity to deal
with that dose so in the linear region
let's say you're somewhat absorbing the
additional effects of dose by capacity
of the repair DNA or repair cells then
when to exceed that threshold you're
beyond that point so that could be a
plausible mechanism for why there could
be a linear quadratic model that could
be testable certainly with a single cell
or multi cell studies like these these
are radiation micro beams or you know
injecting something that would be
absorbed by oneself to irradiated and
seeing what the ones nearby do so you
could count that as number of mutations
number of cell deaths anything something
that could be quantitatively tested so
that's pretty cool I actually quite
liked this study it's awfully hard to
poke a hole in in the logic used here
the claims aren't outrageous they're
saying this is what the data is saying
if you change the model you can it can
or not have a threshold and still get an
acceptable fit
can we actually look in the study itself
one thing I want to do is what sort of
do they do meta-analysis or did they
yeah so this was on the Japanese atomic
bomb survivors so did they analyze the
previous data urban they get their own
and then if so what was the sample size
somewhere they'll be like yeah
where am I virtually be looking at for
this probably further down any sort of
methodology section of materials and
methods here we go okay there it is
eighty six thousand five hundred
something survivors
oh yeah that's with lots of fall
my god is a good question because
especially if we're looking like low
dose and you're estimating it's very
easy to like estimate wrong early cuz
benefit be causing the question you have
hearing
so that's a great question is how do
they know what dose people got so how
would we go about trying to trace that
this is when you dig back in time they
reference this the data of Pierce at all
whatever whatever so if you can go to
web science and pull up this pierce em
all away on the paper look at the cited
references this yeah right there and
look for that 1996 Pierce study let's
see if it hasn't
you can just like control that for
Pierce
Pearse and she needs to be up 1996
that's the one which one this one yep so
let's see if we can trace this back and
find out how they estimated the dose of
these folks should I just go to full
text yeah
so interesting this LLS cohort so there
was some lifespan study which was also
referred to actually in the lecture
notes isn't one of the original studies
it says who met certain conditions and
preserving adequate follow-up although
estimates of the outcomes in next page
although we estimate that might be what
we're looking for
number of survivors
okay here we go materials and methods
the portion of the LSS cohort used here
includes eight the same number of
survivors for whom dos estimates are
currently available etc with estimated
doses greater than five millisieverts is
table wanax summarizing the exposure
distribution so let's go find Table one
and see where the data came from
so it turns out that this is
specifically the SAT six weighted
cold-induced
I don't know but it sounds like we need
to find this LSS just so let's look at
the things that this paper sites find
this LSS so I'm going I'm doing here is
walking you through how to do your own
research and if someone comes to you
with some internet emotional argument of
this and that about radiation is wrong
instead of yelling back louder which
even who lost the argument you hit the
books this is how you do the research
probably title not available it's not
that can you search for LSS
nothing so let's go back to the paper
and find what citation happens if you go
up a little bit I think there was like a
su a superscript up to the last page I'm
sorry
there was a superscript on LSS
general documentation of the selection
of
thank you all right let's find
references 9 and 10 in the yeah so call
me I feel honored
oh yeah they're awesome
nine and ten okay let's fight
so let me show you quickly how to use by
those signs to get what you're looking
for if I could jump on you don't have to
yeah
but thank you for being up here for so
long and running this so we're looking
for where was the article was here went
into references I guess that was like
the last I don't want to close all your
tabs there we go
so GW is at be banned Segawa so we'll go
to web of science look for authors any
paper with those authors so you can do a
more advanced search this is where
things get really interesting and
specific so ditch the topic search by
Beebe and add a field tsugawa and then
anything with these two folks in the
author field that is indexed by web of
science will pop up nothing
I spill anything wrong Segawa of course
that's unfortunate last thing to try is
add wildcards
interesting
this is actually one place where I would
use Google to find a specific report
so because you're not looking to survey
a field that's out there but you're
looking for a document that you can
confirm is that document let's head
there Oh looks like Stanford's got it
that's something that references it so
at this point we've hit the maximum that
we can do on the computer but if you
finally want to trace back to see how
were the Hiroshima data acquired take
these citations bring it to one of the
MIT librarians like Chris Sharat is our
nuclear librarian and we have a nuclear
librarian
yeah MIT libraries is pretty awesome so
when you're looking for anything here in
terms of research or whatever there's
actually someone whose job it is to help
you find nuclear documents and chances
are this is a pretty big one so I
wouldn't be surprised if we have a
physical or electronic coffee so we're
now like one degree of separation away
from finding the original hiroshima data
where we can find out how did they
estimate that dose so I think this is
fairly hopefully this is fairly
instructive to show you how do you go
about getting the facts to prove or
disprove something knowing the not just
the physics that you know about how to
go out and find that stuff now I did see
a bunch of sources from the pro hormesis
team you still want me to show okay
good thanks
alright you just want to hold this up
while you're let's go to your sources
okay here we go so walk us through what
you found I just need to open them up
there's not too much
okay so unfortunately was not able to
find like too many pretty graphs or data
or anything of the sort but if you look
up what did I search for this I think I
just looked up radiation hormesis and
this is one of the articles that turned
up and it seems to be pretty well sited
you can see it's been cited 184 times
and kind of the quick look through the
citations from what I saw seem to be in
support of it and if you actually look
at the abstract itself where is it
yeah well the last sentence is pretty
excellent this is consistent with data
both from animal studies and human
epidemiological observations on low-dose
induced cancer the linear no-threshold
hypothesis should be abandoned and
should and be replaced by a hypothesis
that is scientifically justified and
causes less unreasonable fear and
unnecessary expenditure yeah so
unfortunately the MIT libraries does not
have an electronic copy of this article
and it wasn't able to find one but going
through some of the citations for it
sure yes do not know how to do that
it appears to be a conference okay not
all conferences require peer review in
order to present papers
so while conference proceedings will
typically be published as a record of
what happened at the conference we don't
know if this one was peer reviewed and
checked for facts by an independent
party could you go up a little bit and
maybe leave me some information
oh it didn't go in the British Journal
of radio okay that's a good sign so
conference proceedings you don't know
but in order to publish something in a
journal you do because then in order to
get in the journal things have to be
peer-reviewed to meet the journal
standards regardless of whether they
came from a conference or just a regular
submission so okay that's good to know
and then one of the key sentences that I
found right here
adaptive protection causes DNA damage
prevention and repair and immune system
or immune stimulation it develops with a
delay of hours may last for days to
months decreases steadily at doses above
about 100 milligram elgrand is not
observed anymore after acute exposures
of more than about 500 milligram
that's all pretty interesting like I
said unfortunately I couldn't find the
actual paper so you can't really delve
into some of those claims but I tried to
look at some of the citations that
delved into them and this is where my
presentation gets a little bit shaky er
because I'm not particularly good at
parsing some of this complex stuff very
quickly all right
if you could click download full text -
PDF a little speed bigger okay
so it seems to me this one was more
looking through the statistics of
various studies but I think the
conclusion
here we go
so the very last paragraph the present
practice assumes linearity and assessing
risk from even the lowest dose exposure
of complex tissue to ionizing radiation
by applying this type of risk assessment
to radiation protection of exposed
workers and the public alike society may
gain a questionable benefit and
unavoidably substantial cost research on
the p-values given above may eventually
reveal the true risk which appears to be
inaccessible by epidemiological studies
alone so it seems like they're saying
that at the current there's not really a
problem a statistically valid assertion
of the linear no-threshold model and
that the benefits to society gained from
that are not worth the cost to society
from that assumption so what sort of
costs do you think society incurs by
adapting I mean it could pose
unnecessary regulations on like nuclear
power which could be arguably better for
society sure nuclear power plants emit
radiations in fact to use the old
cellphone there's always going to be
some there is small amount of tritium
release the question is doesn't matter
and if legislation is made to say
absolutely no tritium leases on the
release is allowed well you're not gonna
be allowed to run a nuclear plant that's
not the question we should be asking the
question we should be asking is how much
is harmful so I think that's what this
study is really getting at is I'm glad
to see someone say you may have benefit
but the cost is not worth the benefit
like I I had multiple of the same
arguments
when they were complaining well how dare
would you expose me to any amount of
radiation at any risk that I can't
control I used to protest outside Draper
labs so 30 years protesting nuclear
power and I was like okay how'd you get
there they're like god I drove what in a
car you know do you even know the risks
per mile of getting on the road let
alone in Cambridge specifically no well
I was like you should really consider
where you put your effort it's again
it's emotions versus numbers I'm gonna
go with numbers because I tend to make
bad decisions when I follow my emotions
as do most people because most decisions
are more complex than fight or flight
a lot of the urban students seem to like
really
buried over here
but legally there's a certain extent
they all like you will see like many
movies
you make a great point that's why I like
your chosen idea so much is well you
didn't say chill zone that's what I yeah
yeah the question we should be asking
ourselves is not what is the dose wrist
relationship but when should we actually
care
so like both sets of studies are kind of
come to the conclusion that yeah and
then I found out this last one is a
little bit more assertive it's kind of
just hitting the same nail on kind of
the elimination of the linear
no-threshold model but then it does go
on to make some more powerful claim
right here these data are examined
within the context of low-dose radiation
induction of cellular signaling that may
stimulate cell cellular protection
systems over hours to weeks against
accumulation of DNA damage I believe so
yeah okay and then yes we can look up
the full text on Google Scholar that's
okay when you know what you're looking
for you can verify it that's that's a
useful thing for Google is like to find
no content but if you're trying to
survey a field Google
not yet I'm sure I'm sure they're
working on it but they're not assigns
anybody see it get the full paper button
oh wait right here right yeah okay sign
in oh I was able to get to it somehow
yeah okay but this one and then this one
this one just had some nice data if I'm
gonna summarize it had it was looking at
the amount of DNA damage instances
compared normal background dose to like
very very low dose and the very very low
dose was significantly less than the
normal background dose so I just kind of
shows that like very low levels of
radiation are like no worse for you than
just background as which is interesting
if you want to send it to me I'll put it
up here alright I minimize because I
didn't just want to leave your email oh
I don't care if there's nothing you okay
I'll bring it back up so that's all the
ones you sent actually this is this one
this debates turning out a whole lot
more interesting than previously because
uh well cuz you're thinking it's
actually really nice to see this and
this is the I'm not surprised don't
worry it's just pleasant to have a
debate about something controversial
with a whole group of people who are
thinking and researching rather than
shouting and like throwing plates or oh
no you'd if you want throw a chair but I
might throw one back
I wonder if anyone's gone out recently
and has come up with all of the Pro and
anti her Mesa studies and actually
written a paper that says that's not the
point because really what we're getting
huh you know I think you could write
that bacon now it would make for a
pretty cool undergrad thesis actually
yeah maybe I can tell you a little bit
about what an undergrad thesis actually
entails because the seniors are all
asking but it's good for you to know
ahead of time so the main requirement
for an undergrad thesis is it's got to
be your work that doesn't mean you have
to have collected the data yourself like
done an experiment but it has to be some
original thought or idea or accumulation
of yours
so trying to settle this debate and
trying to figure out what would be a
proposed chill region to say forget the
linear threshold or no threshold that's
for the basic scientist if you are a
government and want to legislate
something that actually captures should
people be afraid or not defining that
region would be a pretty cool study to
do in the meta analysis of lots of other
studies tracing back how were the I mean
a lot of people refer to the Hiroshima
data set because that's about the
biggest one we have in addition to folks
with radon or folks that smoke it's they
were all exposed to the same thing in
the relatively same area so it's a good
controlled group of people but how much
how are those doses estimated didn't
you'd have to dig that up and the act of
digging that up and then recasting all
these new studies in the basis of
everything we've learned since would
make for a pretty cool undergrad thesis
topic
so as undergrad chair I wouldn't say no
to that
threshold and other departures from
linear quadratic curvature in the same
data set appears to visit the LSS data
set let's try to get the full-text
awesome I think it's looking good
great
I've seen that name before interesting
interesting they proposed another model
called a power of dosa power law and
they say depending on this there's
little evidence that it's statistically
different from one which is a what do
they call one linear threshold quadratic
threshold or linear quadratic threshold
okay
so again it's it seems to be yet another
paper saying don't think it matters
statistics says it doesn't matter you
could fit any model to this data
let's get to the methods
interesting
so dose-response for all non cancer
mortality in the atomic bomb survivors
so also in this case it's mortalities
not caused by cancer
so this would be think what they're
getting at is is there a response or is
there a change in the amount of
mortality not due to cancer and the or
in this case health detriments right
because in this ghetto it never goes
negative can't really tell in some cases
let's see
yeah quite hard to tell especially
considering a so what the low-dose is
what would you guys say for the low dose
data I see a pretty well-defined chill
zone right there right we're definitely
still in the chill zone at point four
sieverts of colon dose and that's a
pretty hefty amount of dose you know
we're talking eight or nine times the
allowed amount that you're able to get
in a year from occupational safety
limits once the doses get higher things
seems to get a little more deterministic
or statistically significant but yeah
look at all the different models the
linear threshold quadratic threshold
linear quadratic threshold power of dose
all goes straight through not just like
in the arrow bars but almost straight
through most of the data points except
for the really far away ones so this is
a pretty neat study showing like hey the
relationship does not appear to matter
for doses of consequence I would call to
see Bert's a dose of consequence based
on our earlier discussion of biological
effects luckily it doesn't go much
farther than that you don't want a lot
of people that have received doses
beyond 10 GRA but this is pretty
compelling to me to say like we can
argue about what the real model is and
what the underlying mechanism is but is
this a question we really should be
asking ourselves when the total risk
let's say when the total risk to an
organism reaches about a hundred percent
once you reach a dose where it doesn't
even matter then is this a question that
we should really be debating in the
public sphere
I love the outcome of this particular
debate lots of Statistics don't have
time to parse
is there anything else Chris that you
wanted to highlight in this study
oh okay oh maybe it was a UK Pierce I
think
that's pretty cool so anyone else have
any other papers they want to show for
or against or for our sort of collective
new conclusion which is that we should
just relax cool well that way yeah
Charlie
so let's say you could prove beyond a
shadow of a doubt that a little bit of
radiation exposure was a good thing you
might then prescribe radiation
treatments in order to reap the benefits
I don't think there's been a single
study that shows that there's like
deterministic benefits from a radiating
people some of the studies show that
folks that have gotten exposed via
various routes do show a lower incidence
of cancer so you could almost think of
it like a vitamin not an ingestible
vitamin but so back there are lots of
pictures online and stories of way up in
the north and Russia and in northern
countries they'd expose you to
ultraviolet radiation to stimulate the
production of vitamin D in your skin
cells because in the absence of an
ingestible source of vitamin D you make
it naturally but not when there's
eternal darkness so that actually have
kids stand in front of a UV lamp which
does have ill effects that can cause
also skin cancers but the benefits of
the organism in generating vitamin D
that you need for health are greater so
that might be an example these these
sorts of ideas are not that far-fetched
if you put little kids in front of UV
lamps what you know can do bad things
but also does more good things than
who's to say it shouldn't happen for
radiation well no one's to say yet
because we have no real conclusive proof
that it is helpful but that was yeah
you mean in for radiation or for
something else though the mechanisms of
so that one study that Chris showed that
what was the idea that no there so here
the first one that you show the mouse
one and then the one that Chris
mentioned where a little bit of
radiation dose stimulated the immune
system that might be a potential good
thing where the damage or death of a few
cells may stimulate the nearby ones to
ramp up an immune response the snuffing
out any other infection or problem
that's coming up that will could be a
use but it would have to be proved with
much more confidence than anything I've
seen today so that's a good question
yeah like how would you use it use it
like a vitamin like a UV lamp like a sad
lamp
although I don't think sad lamps do
anything bad the seasonal affective
disorder the most unfortunate acronym in
the world yeah yes I don't know if that
would be easy to swallow yeah cool all
right any other thoughts from this
exercise I think I'll do more
interactive classes like this it's good
to hear you guys talk for a change cool
okay
you